direction maintenant les états unis
après des jours de controverse la
compagnie aérienne américaine southwest
airlines a finalement renoncé à des
mesures punitives pour ses salariés non
vaccinés on en parle avec notre
correspondant à washington thomas bonnet
bonsoir thomas et c'est donc un
retournement de situation saluée comme
une victoire par ceux qui militent
contre l'obligation vaccinale
oui la compagnie aérienne southwest
airlines a finalement décidé de renoncer
a placé en congé sans solde les salariés
qui ne seront pas vaccinés d'ici la date
butoir du 8 décembre prochain à la place
les employés en question devront
présenter à minima une preuve qu'ils ont
demandé une procédure d'exemption pour
des motifs des motifs médicaux ou
religieux et puis ensuite ils devront se
conformer aux règles sanitaires en
vigueur dans l'entreprise notamment avec
le port du masque alors ces derniers
jours à cette compagnie aérienne était
devenu un symbole pour les opposants aux
obligations de vaccination il y avait
même eu des manifestations comme ici à
dallas je vous propose d'écouter
quelques uns des participants
nous sommes ici pour défendre la liberté
et nous sommes ici pour soutenir les
employés de south west qui défendent
leur droit de travailler sans être forcé
de se faire vacciner sans être forcé de
subir un licenciement en raison de leur
choix médicaux c'est un choix il s'agit
de liberté et il s'agit de défendre nos
droits en tant qu'américains
il est important que nous soyons tous
solidaires et que nous défendrons nos
droits inaliénables comme notre
intégrité physique et que le
gouvernement ne nous impose pas les
vaccins contre notre volonté
alors si le sort de lait de ses salariés
de cette compagnie aérienne southwest
airlines et bien été si médiatisé c'est
parce que la semaine dernière la
compagnie a dû annuler des milles et de
vol elle a écarté tout lien entre ces
annulations et la mise en place de
l'obligation de vaccination mais les
justifications de l'entreprise en
expliquant que ces animations étaient
dus à la météo n'ont pas à réellement
convaincu et c'est d'ailleurs certains
ont mis en avant cette affaire pour
illustrer le fait que la mise en place
de l'obligation de vaccination avait un
impact très réel sur un certain nombre
de secteurs d'activité
l' affaire a pris une telle ampleur que
même le président américain joe biden a
fini par prendre la parole à ce sujet
c'était la semaine dernière écouter
le chef du syndicat des pilotes et le
pdg de southwest airlines ou rejeter
l'accusation que l'obligation vaccinale
contribueraient aux perturbations du
trafic aérien des représentants de
l'éducation des chefs religieux et des
docteurs dans tout le pays lutte contre
la désinformation et sensibilise la
population à l'importance de la
vaccination
tous ces efforts vont nous permettre de
continuer à déplacer le curseur
d'éliminer cette maladie
la question maintenant c'est de savoir
si cette décision de southwest airlines
peut créer un précédent dans une
amérique très divisé sur la question de
l'obligation de vaccination c'est une
division aussi politique puisque vous
avez d'un côté des états républicains
comme le texas par exemple qui ont tout
simplement interdit la mise en place des
obligations de vaccination et dans le
même temps le maire démocrate de la
ville de new york a annoncé ce mercredi
que tous les employés municipaux de la
ville devront maintenant être vaccinés
merci thomas bonnet en direct de
washington reste à vie